do you know humans have a no way of
sensing wetness no I heard that oh I saw
this year we just know there's like we
can tell the temperature difference yeah
yeah
I saw that yeah I found it really
interesting because I'm like how many
other things can't I sense but I can
just sense like sense a bad take when
you have it guys that's another thing
you can't say it's a dark thoughts
yeah I think I'm pretty confident
[Music]
do you feel like you can tell if
someone's looking at you yes why why why
do we feel like we can tell like I've
had I've had points where I've been like
asleep or just like napping or something
and I'm like someone's looking at me I
look up and someone is I think someone
okay well that's okay that's [__]
first of all I think that's just
coincidence
I think we take a note to like again I
think we said some previous episodes um
we're like again we're extremely
socially focused animals yeah and so I
think that's like an evolutionary trait
that's kind of been like malfunctioned a
little bit where we're like we don't I
guess we kind of still need it but we
don't need to be as socially accepted as
we once needed to yeah so we we're very
attentive to anything social for the
most part so I think when when people
are staring at us we're really apparent
of it and we're really bad at even like
thinking was God just staring at me like
I feel like God was just staring at me
right yeah yeah I feel like you're just
looking at my direction I start in the
corner of miles
overthink it yeah we can kind of sense
if like someone is Feeling Again a
certain way or like if a situation is
uncomfortable that's my [__] theory
that could be totally wrong I'm pretty
sure that's where it comes from is that
we're very very in tune with being
socially yeah I mean like you want to
know if you ask any other animal it's
like uh so can you tell if that prawn is
feeling
they'll be like no I can't give a [__]
what does that mean why would you why
would you need to sense that God dogs
are [__] cute though I wonder if a
dog knows a dog knows I'm staring at it
I just want to pet a dog
it always knows it always like a dog can
always tell like when when when you're
like giving it some attention you could
be on the other side
my dog used to do that when it was just
like kind of just sitting there just
like staring off into Blank Space
sometimes I would just you know look at
my dog because I'm like you're a good
boy you're a pretty boy and then
sometimes the dog would just kind of do
this like
why you walk over at me like what what
do you want every every time you know
like I'm I'm torn right in my head and
whether I think God exists because I'm
like okay God makes stuff that that
kills children and I'm like that's
pretty [__] out yeah but then we also
have videos like dogs cuddling people
who are sad and I'm like well how do you
explain that you know why the dog
evolved to know when we're sad and it
helps us that's pretty I feel like
somebody must have helped that out come
on yeah we don't deserve it you know
look what we've done in history do we
really deserve that we don't maybe we
should not think of God as this
omnipotent being that knows everything
maybe if there is a God in this world
they can make mistakes
um and I'm just saying dog like when
they created the dog that was like I
this is the biggest W of my [__] life
is the only reason why we accept NTR
because dogs exist I think we'd all be
done I think they would have been that
would have been the final straw there
needs to be an equal evil to create an
equal doctor has bought this omnipotent
power so much time yeah frankly you know
and I I I and people who are allergic
they got done dirty but yeah but they
came a lot yeah and then [__] like
God was listening to [__] Metallica
one day and I was like [__] mantis
shrimp man I'm gonna make one of those
man let's [__] do it there's some
whack [__] that has been like
evolutionized so you're like that that
is interesting
like what uh well uh um the Mantis trip
is certainly one of them yeah like this
feels like the most over engineered
Evolution to a problem right like
right when you think about it you're
like this feels like respect far too
much for no reason it's it's it's like I
look at the Mantra the reason I love
that Manta stream is I don't think it's
the most optimal way to achieve what you
want to achieve which is get food yeah
but I respect the fact that you
committed so hard to this one solution
yeah like you look at you know an animal
like a highly intelligent animal like an
octopus right that is like all right you
know it can problem solve it can like
you know figure out more intelligent
ways to catch its prey like camouflage
or like tricking its prey meanwhile
mantis shrimp is like I punch hard I
destroy I like the fact that for some
reason obviously it makes sense
evolutionary wise but just owls could
just [__] turn their head mostly all
the way around yeah yeah that feels like
the owl was kind of being a little lazy
all right I'm not gonna lie I feel like
the owl could have maybe just turned
around a little bit just
if I could turn my head all the way
around do I really need that I feel like
yeah I don't know man to be honest if
someone asked me hey would you want the
ability this is very much a shower
thought yeah would you want the ability
to turn your head almost 360 degrees
Yeah I'd be like I don't know when I'd
use it but sure well why not what I want
to know is you know we we talk about
like animals and food chain and even if
you don't like an animal or something we
love talking animals yeah we love
animals animals
um having said that is there a single
redeeming quality of a mosquito or can
we remove mosquitoes and
I'm sure something will be a fact
there'd be no adverse effects at all I
think I remember seeing like some videos
about that of like some like experts
argue that we can but with like a little
bit of a of a deficit to the food chain
and then there are others that say like
no it's it was just completely if we've
learned anything we are really [__]
bad at getting involved with the [__]
and trying to control nature we've been
we've historically have a terrible
tracker yeah yeah
um yeah we're just pretty bad at it I
think there's a kind of the sentiment
um we shouldn't do it we're just like
what if we just make this Animal League
Scene It won't [__] off the food chain
right the animal Kingdom's like what are
you doing stop
I know they're delicious like I made
this chain very precisely and you're
[__] it up I just want to know if
there's any anything any animal anything
that has something positive to say about
mosquitoes well do animals hate
mosquitoes problem so I'm sure even
spiders like I mean I eat them but I can
go without them
flies you know I I can live without
mosquitoes you know I don't know
hard to say man is there anything cooler
than a mantis shrimp I don't think so
I'm I'm a Google is now coolest
animals well there's that there's that
video of the guy who was like out
fishing in a canoe and he like he
accidentally fished up a mantis shrimp
and it like it quickly like flicked him
in the in the toe like just like oh yeah
he broke it and it broke his top yeah I
saw that and he's like he's like ah and
then he like releases it back in and
like his foot is bleeding and then later
on he's like I I'm in the hospital
because uh my toe is broken I'm like
what oh [__] that's insane that's pretty
[__] wild yeah that's wild
God I think I think I've evolved to just
drink tea it's just British isn't it I
was on the plane back uh from my
Christmas break and I swear to God it
was embarrassing the amount of tea I
drank I just kept asking for more tea
and they were like and they came around
and they were like tea I was like yes
bring it I think I drank like 15 Cups of
Tea holy [__] isn't that insane why is
that because I was just I was thirsting
for some hot liquid
it's what I like all right honestly ever
since moving to Japan I drink far too
much green tea I don't know can you
drink too much green tea because I'm
definitely drinking it's got caffeine
you actually can drink too much tea
um there's some like uh there's a few
chemicals in it that are pretty bad if
you drink it like all the time all day
um but like anything that's like that
right if you ate just [__] ham yeah
sure
just lettuce you'd have no nothing else
right I mean everything in moderation
generally yeah oh yeah I'm just like how
much tea is like too much tea you know
um I'm definitely surpassing it I'm
pretty sure
um but that's a problem for future me
yeah I feel like I'm in the now you know
I'm I'm trying to worry about that
that's that's that's the video you
should make five years from now being
like the tea didn't kill you sorry about
that you know how it is you should film
it while you're sipping a cup of tea
it's like I bet you're mad yeah that's
that's like that's like a fault in like
human evolution we are so we are so
inadequate in try with like we can
process problems that will happen in our
future but we're so inadequate in caring
about it you know
like yep that's why global warming has
been yeah right I was just about to say
like climate change activism like first
time yeah like hey your body is going to
deteriorate if you don't exercise and
keep healthy every day and you know eat
good and you're like yeah but one more
hamburger right one more Burger
literally every person who smokes
cigarettes is just like yeah I know but
that's that's future me to decide I'm
I'm enjoying it right that it takes so
much energy just to like care about it
and change your life for the better it
just it just yeah some something's wrong
with the brain the creatures of habits
man when we get in a habit we it's hard
for us to kill we didn't put enough
points into intelligence
we've programmed our brain to work in
the best way it can and it's got a lot
of flaws yeah yeah right I mean I did
program I'm [__] lazy that's someone
else did that
I don't know it's weird